يعرف صاحبه كما تعرف الفرس خيالها لا يطلق
النار الا اذا تعرف على وجه مالكه
التكنولوجيا اقتحمت مؤخرا عالم الاسلحه
الفرديه واحدث انجازاتها هذا المسدس الذكي
الذي يعتبر الاكثر تطورا في فئته من
الاسلحه مسدس لا يعمل الا بعد التاكد من
بصمه وجه صاحبه
الامريكيه في مدينه كولورادو طورت سلاحا
يطلق نيرانه فقط بعد التاكد من بصمه خاصه
مرتبطه بوجه مستخدمه هذا المسدس سيكون
وجوده اكثر امانا في البيت ومع الاطفال
كما تقول الشركه اذ لا يمكن لاي احد يحمله
ان يطلق النار ولابد من فك جفرته باستخدام
وجه المستخدم الاصلي فقط بنفس الطريقه
تماما التي تعمل بها الهواتف الذكيه لفتح
اقفالها في امريكا تقع مئات الحوادث والاف
الضحايا نتيجه اطلاق النار العشوائي
الاحصائيات مرعبه والضحايا يتساقطون دون
سن اي قانون رادع لمثل تلك الجرائم لذا
فكرت شركه بوي فاير تلك الامريكيه في حل
ذكي قد يساهم في الحد من استخدام
المراهقين لاسلحه ابائهم التي تكون
بمنازلهم دون رقيب
المسدس الذكي الجديد يمكن ايضا فتحه
وتشغيله بواسطه قارئ بصمات الاصابع وهي
واحده من العديد من ميزات هذا السلاح
الجديد
الشركه المطوره تقول ان ذلك ربما سيقلل من
حالات اطلاق النار بالخطا من قبل الاطفال
وتقليل حالات الانتحار كما ان هذا
الاختراع سيساهم في جعل الاسلحه المفقوده
او المسروقه عديمه الفائده
اثناء تجربه المسدس في مقر شركه بيوفر
اطلق كلوب فير مؤسس الشركه طلقه دون مشكله
ثم حاول رجل اخر وهو مستخدم غير مصرح له
اطلاق النار لكنه لم يتمكن من ذلك لان
المسدس لم يتعرف على وجهه ولا بصمه اصبعه
هذا المسدس المتطور سيكون من عيار تسعه
مليمترات ويمكن للعملاء طلبه من الشركه
بسعر يصل لالف
كما تعمل الشركه على تطوير بنادق واسلحه
فرديه اخرى مزوده بتقنيات مماثله